la presse plus ce matin nous apprend
qu'un manuel qui a été signé par un
prêtre et un médecin encourage les
familles à retirer les enfants des
classes d'éducation sexuelle et de
prendre en charge cette responsabilité
l'abbé robert gendron directeur du
service de pastorale liturgique à
l'archevêché de montréal et co auteur de
ce manuel monsieur jean dotto bout du
fil bonjour oui bonjour est ce que le
votre document ce manuel est recommandée
et appuyé par l'archevêché de montréal
non c'est une affaire qui est absolument
de l'apostolat personnel a poussé le
personnel
oui alors qu'est ce qu'il est à dire que
tout le groupe de 2,2 par un que je avec
eux la campagne et qui ont quelques uns
sont arrivés après plusieurs mois de
réflexion et puis monsieur le docteur
ayasse avait proposé quelque chose et
puis moi j'ai collaboré à la rédaction
de ce sont donc les affaires de monsieur
hire témoins est ce que est ce que la
chirurgie par contre est ce que c'est
vrai l'article on peut le lire relais le
manuel dit que c'est disponible
enfin une certaine promotion non c'est
plutôt une information qu'elle fait
parce qu'ils s'attaquent on ferme des
parents catholiques qui peuvent être
intéressés mais on peut pas dire qu'ils
l'appuient
mais il ne rejette pas non plus une
information simplement ça donne
l'impression qu'on vous dit que c'est à
titre personnel mais quand vous occuper
des fonctions comme les vôtres comment
pouvez-vous dissocier le fait que quand
on a le directeur de la pastorale
liturgique qui écrit manuel convient de
dire ensuite que c'est à titre personnel
vous engagez plus que votre simple
personnes écoutées c'est vrai que mon
travail fait que je suis proche dans de
l'organisation de l'église catholique à
montréal cependant si j'étais curé ce
serait la même chose si j'étais un
aumônier d'hôpital de faire la même
chose alors on a quand même une certaine
autonomie
c'est pas moi qui fait la promotion de
mon poste c'est qu'on me demande des
fauves et que je travaille à quelque
part oui qu'est ce que vous dites qu est
ce que vous êtes dans ce document
pourquoi
qu'est ce que vous suggérez aux parents
écoutez la proche de ce programme est
intéressant c'est à dire dans mon à mon
sens c'est parce que ce n'est pas un
rejet du programme
voyez vous c'est très important parce
qu'il ya des parents qui vont peu trop
peut-être vouloir le rejeter mais ce
n'est pas notre approche
notre approche c'est plutôt de retirer
l'enfant du moment où le professeur
donne le contenu d'une partie du
programme
il est formé par un avec lesquels n'ya
pas surprenant quand il est par un deal
nous allons donner le contenu du
programme parce que voyez-vous les
objectifs principaux du gouvernement
sont tout à fait acceptables par
l'église je pense pas résister également
quel programme et je trouve ce gros que
c'est une agression
oui peut-être une agression quand on
parle là des enfants qui sont pas prêts
à entendre parler des parties sexuelles
de de l'un et de l'autre
quand ils les parents peuvent trouver
que c'est une agression alors on veut
les protéger
c'est en tant que cette certaine entente
avec le pauvre vous parlez ce que c'est
légal
écoutez je crois que voyez-vous le grand
impose aux programmes le directeur
d'école doit voir que ces professeurs
l'appliquent - les professeurs sont
responsables de que le programme passe
aux enfants ouais il ya une entente et
que le professeur dit le programme a été
vu par les enfants et la direction dit
c'est ça qui est important
alors au point de vue légal je crois
bien que c'est pas une confrontation
avec le gouvernement
non je vais les enfants des besoins
particuliers de toutes sortes les
enfants catholiques en aussi ouais mais
est ce que vous pensez pas par la porte
d'en arrière pour ne pas faire ce que
vous pourriez faire par la porte d'en
avant cela une contestation en bonne et
due forme
la contestation déjà été envisagée car
quand j'ai eu le cours de pierre et des
parents qui ont demandé de retirer leurs
enfants et ça leur a été défendu les
catholiques ont perdu là dessus alors
s'aperçoit que c'est pas la bonne quoi
donc vous pouvez vous préférez passer
par un art
pour éviter l'affrontement quand vous
êtes parent arrière c'est un peu
péjoratif je crois pas qu'on se gâche
qu'on fasse des choses de façon
détournée
si c'est vraiment une entente pour dire
on se respecte et on demande au
gouvernement de respecter aussi les les
parents catholiques qui sont les
premiers éducateurs des enfants monsieur
gendron merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à
nos questions
au revoir que je vous en prie revoir